did you know that you can do a behind the scenes tour
of the living on the Land Pavilion
in Epcot as a homeschooling family
I love to incorporate educational activities into our Disney days
and this was a tour that I have been dying to do for a long time now
you have to book your tour ahead of time and it is an additional cost per person
but in my opinion it was a highlight of our trip
we met our tour guide right next to the Thorn Ride in the land Pavilion
and then we got to go behind the scenes and look at the greenhouses
and see how all the Disney Imagineers created innovative growing techniques
as avid gardeners and lovers of nature
this was such an incredible experience
we brought our nine and eight year old because this would count as earth science
because in my opinion
there's no better way to learn something than being able to touch
see and feel it for yourself
the tour was about an hour and took you through three different rooms
showing you the growing techniques that Disney has come up with
and ways that they've innovated growth techniques
and share that technology with the world
one of my favourite things we saw was the hydroponic lettuce system
that they were growing for some of the restaurants here in Disney World
later in the trip
my husband and I actually got to eat a salad at Tiffin's Restaurant
in Animal Kingdom where they grow all the lettuces for
and in true Disney fashion
our tour guide was funny entertaining
and informative he explained why they grow the plants they do
and specifically with the salad
why they use different lettuce varieties
my husband is a big gardening aficionado and loves to tinker
so seeing the trellis systems
and how they grow such large quantities of vegetables in such small spaces
keeping the fruit off the ground
and keeping pests at the minimum gave him tons of ideas for our Home Garden
the tour group was only about 10 people
so everybody got to ask questions
and really interact with the tour guide along the tour
everyone forgets that Disney is also an innovator in so many industries
including ecology and environmental conservation
the work that they're doing with ecology and conservation
and specifically in the land Pavilion
was so cool to see up close
our kids favourite part was definitely when we went inside
to see the tanks full of tilapia
and learn about why they are the perfect fish to farm in close quarters
we actually also got to see a lot of the boats coming through
for the living off the land ride
and then feed the tilapia and help
we truly became part of someone's Disney experience
I highly recommend this behind the scenes Disney experience for your next trip